crossing the sound bear is much like
crossing the speed limit on the highway
you don't really notice anything
um
to cross that at least in f 18 because
we have a lot more weight than most
fighters is typically we'll do that in a
descent
and we'll do that a full afterburner uh
just dumping gas into the engine
um and so that'll get us over the
fastest i think i've gone with about
1.28
but what's interesting people realize is
that if i take that throttle and i'm an
afterburner and i just bring it back and
just bring it back to mill which is full
power just not afterburner
the de-acceleration is so strong due to
the air friction that it throw you
forward in your straps almost you know i
would say you know maybe like 70 percent
of strong almost as has trapping on the
boat it's pretty strong
so it's almost like a reverse car crash
just for the deacceleration so the
acceleration you know is usually kind of
slow and you don't feel anything of
course when you're crossing through it
but the acceleration is pretty violent
the deceleration is violent huh okay uh
but is there
is there a fundamental difference
between like mach 1 and hypersonic mach
5 and so on does it require like super
special training
and is that something that's
used often in warfare is that not really
that no so hypersonic human flight in if
it exists is not something that's
employed tactically
in um in any sense right now that i'm
aware of so
um you know i think of hypersonic
technology i think of uh missiles and
weapon systems and delivery platform i
don't think of uh fighter aircraft
necessarily i can think of bomber or
reconnaissance aircraft perhaps
but those would be more efficient very
long long range i imagine acceleration
would be kind of gentle honestly
the thing you experience is the
acceleration not the actual speed
you